police in Los Angeles say they've
identified more victims of the man who
allegedly posed as a real estate agent
to steal from Hollywood celebrities
investigators say a suspect was arrested
and they confiscated thousands of stolen
items the valuables were taken from
stars like singer Usher Jason Derulo and
Adam Lambert Carter Evans is outside one
of the homes that was targeted in
Tarzana section of Los Angeles Carter
good morning good morning this is a
wealthier neighborhood in Los Angeles
with a lot of gated homes now one of
them was the home of Jason Derulo which
was targeted back in 2017 now police
have posted pictures of all these stolen
items online hoping people will
recognize their belongings and come
forward when he showed up he was dressed
to the nines he acted the park Los
Angeles police say Benjamin E tan
Ackerman is behind one of the most
brazen and sophisticated string of
burglaries they've ever seen for more
than a year the 32 year old allegedly
posed as a real estate agent showing up
at homes driving high-end luxury cars
and wearing designer clothes he would
sign in under an alias to cases target
returning later to steal items valued in
the millions in some cases apparently
convincing unsuspecting brokers to give
him access to homes a lot of times
people we just want to be friendly and
we don't want to challenge people and
because of that lack of challenging is
how you basically invite the devil in
police say Ackerman tried to cover his
tracks disabling security cameras and
even altering print numbers on stolen
artwork but ultimately a tip from a
victim led then to Ackerman's home and
storage unit containing more than two
thousand stolen items including jewelry
designer handbags and fine wine what I
thought was a little interesting was the
wine the the alcohol there were bottles
of wine worth hundreds and hundreds if
not thousands of dollars so he knew what
he was looking for correct yeah it
wasn't wine you and I are drinking
police have identified more than a dozen
victims so far everyone from uh sure
Jason Derulo and Adam Lambert to a
family friend of the suspect Ackerman
was arrested but released pending a
forensic analysis of the evidence he
could be watching this yes is there
anything you want him to know I would
want them to know that the investigation
is not over you can't go around stealing
from people and you do it long enough
we're gonna catch you now we've reached
out to Ackerman's attorney but have not
heard back police are now trying to
determine if this string of burglaries
is related to another series of
burglaries where the thieves monitored
celebrities social media to see when
they'd be out of town
Norah all right Carter thank you the
long arm of the law will catch you it's
interesting it's an interesting scheme
to pose as a real estate agent that's
it's actually can get a lot of houses
that way very effective and a lot of
expensive wine - yeah if you know you're
one